the beginning
Which I try to do in some upcoming videos that I try to see what
Will happen to an integrative line, either an integrative line (Tam) across through
An inserted field or a vector field (having a size and direction), but what will happen to that complete line
When we change the direction of our way?
Well let's say, when I say change the direction I mean by it
We have some curves (C) that look something like this
We draw the axis (x) and axis (y)
So this axial (y) is axial (x), let's say
The medallion starts from here and the more it grows the more it ends
Above as we have seen now
So she moves in that direction
When I say I will reverse the way we can
Clarification and other curved determination
Let's call it negative (C) like this we are drawing now
This pivotal (y) is axial (x)
They look quite similar to what we have already painted, but they start from here and beyond
The more you grow, the lower you go towards the starting point
Of the other curve
So the shape is exactly the same for the curved but moving
Towards the opposite direction exhibitions
So what I'm going to do in this video will be understanding how
We can build such a proxy representation
We hope that you will understand the way in the best way possible
After this video we will present two topics and try to watch them
Effectively what does this command for the integrated line, once in the dual domain
And once in the vector field
So let's just say that mediating is correct here
Let us just clarify it and know it in the basic way
Which we have always known
Let's say that this x is equal to x for t
And y equals and equalizes the y of t, let's say this is equivalent to t
Let us write it this way
Starting from a is therefore greater than or equal to a
And then move towards the top towards b
So in this example, this situation was when t was adjusted and equated with a
The point here is the x-coordinate of a, and the y-effect of a
Here is the top when t is equal and equal to b is only a
When we want to review what we saw before
The review of the proxy representation will be when t is equal to b above
This is the point x of b, and the y point of b
Nothing new there
Now we have these functions (functions) how we can build
Another little representation here has the same shape
But it starts from here
So here I want t be equivalent to a
Let me change colors
Let's change the current color to purple
Well I want to t tie that, and I've been growing and growing
So I want t equal to b
So I want to move in the opposite direction
So when t be equal to a, I want to make me
X is for b, and y is for b
When t equal a, I want b in each of these disciples?
When t is equal to a, I want a coordinate
x for a, and y for a
Okay ?
Do you notice that they are currently in conflict and disagreeing?
Here t is the equivalent of a, x for a and y for a
Here t equal our final point
Now I am in this x coordinate for a, and y for a.
So how can I build this
Well when you think about, t equalize a we want
Both of these depend on their estimation in b
So what if we set x in this position to give negative C?
What if we say x equals x and here we mean b
x is equal to x of the same child
In fact, I might have to type in a similar color
x for .... but instead of putting t or a or t here sequentially
What if you put a plus b
Minus t there
What will happen ?
Well let's do it for y too
Thus y, y will be equal to y for a plus b minus t
a plus b will be t
Here I use a different light yellow shade perhaps
It will be a bit confused
After all, what happens if we define and know this?
When t is an equation for a, when t is a equation let's say that
The intermediary representation is also specific to the beginning of a
And then go to b
So let's just try and prove that
Intermediary representation is something similar to this
But it is heading in the opposite direction
Or at least make this bitterly fixed in our minds intuitively
So when t is an equation for a and when t is an equation for a, then x is equivalent to
x for a plus minus a, right?
This is when t is equivalent to a negative t or negative a
Which would be equal to what?
Well a minus minus a result is the x result for b.
Concisely when t equals a, y will be equivalent to
y for a plus b minus a
The a will be deleted and the y result of b
Well this was done.
Now when t is equal a proxy representation will be estimated for
X coordinate of b and y of b.
When t is equal to a x of b and y of b.
Then we can do the same thing when t is equivalent to b
I will do it here because I do not want to lose this
Let me just draw a line here
I am still dealing with the intermediary representation of us
In fact let me move to the right
So that it does not mix with me
When t is an equation for b when t equals b what will x equal?
x is equal to a plus b minus b?
a plus b minus b where t is equal to b
So the result will be x for a
When the result is so why is the overlap of a plus b
Minus b and certainly the result will be y for a
If the end point is effective and when you think about it intuitively
Such as t increases when t be in a thing that will be
x for b and y of b
We see this here at the bottom
Now the more t this value will decrease
We start with x for b and y of b, and the higher t this value
Will you fall for a true?
Then start from b and head towards a
This certainly starts from a and goes towards b
So I hope this will give you an intuition of why
This is the same curve as the one before
It just goes completely in the opposite direction
Now if you accept what you have said and explained
That this is the same as the intermediary representation
Only in the opposite direction
I should not say the same representation
But the same curve is heading in the opposite direction or the same way
In the opposite direction
In the next video I will see what happens
When we appreciate this integrative line of x ds
In return for this integrated line
So this is a dual-line field of integrated dual domain
We use this curve and this way but what will happen if
What we have taken this integrative line across the same dual domain however
We will do it across this road or the opposite direction
This is what we will do in the next video
And the next video we will do in the vector field
End